I don't get it really wish I could but I
can't believe that it would it's very
unlikely to happen isn't it
bangers ago Wow
never gonna happen didn't you
didn't you write for a children's comic
I did yeah suddenly no I don't think so
which is more realistic The Avengers or
Dora the Explorer is that's what he
wrote Dora the explora I used to write
for Dora the explora magazine yeah don't
want to don't brag said that's great
he's an actor and he couldn't deliver
that line we've got we've got an issue
of the magazine that Josh contributed to
write the whole thing mate you wrote
this whole magazine committee no family
six pages there's a nice poem in it
I write the poem yeah yeah silly steps
it's about how to do a funny dance yes
can I just say before you read out this
isn't my finest work this issue this job
really
so stretch and pull your mouth and wide
to make a silly grin squid your face
between your hands go on squish it in
rhymes but this is the bit where I think
Dora really what Dora sing this stick
your bottom out behind you and to wiggle
it wiggle it to and throne could I just
say this was a different time now make
the favorite silly face
I do the silliest that's you know I
think it rhymes and scans it it works
and you know what else it was a job it
played big in the 2230
it's not easy what are you afraid of
well I was gonna go with flying but I
think I'll go with girls over 12